First up we have a story on talking monkeys.
Why can't monkeys talk?
What would they say if they could?
And most importantly, what would they sound like?
Dave, did you have an imagined monkey voice
in your head, before hearing the
clip we are about to play?
I guess, Cesear from Planet of the Apes.
Although I know he's not a monkey
--he is a chimpanzee.
Something a little deep, a little guttural, maybe.
I had the monkey butler voice in my head,
The smooth, British monkey butler voice.
Ok, so now I'm going to play the clip
Will you marry me?
That's what it sounds like have you heard it?
Yes.
So, your idea of what a monkey voice sounded like--
it wasn't creepy, beyond the grave--type
marriage proposal, like we just heard.
Why does this sound the way it does?
Where did the research team come up with this voice?
This all goes back to this question of
why can't our closest primate relatives --
chimps, bonobos, even monkeys
-- why can't they talk?
And for a long time, scientists thought
well maybe they just don't have the
right vocal anatomy to talk.
Maybe their vocal cords aren't arranged
in the right way or whatever.
But that isn't satisfying --
especially when you consider
that animals like parrots and elephants can
make noises actually very similar to human speech
and they have a radically different anatomy than we do
and that a lot of our primate relatives do.
So the alternate explanation is that their brains
aren't controlling their physiology
the way our brains control our physiology.
Right.
The researchers tried to figure out which was the case.
They turned to a long-tail macaque named Emiliano
and they didn't ask him to talk.
but what they did do is they had him sit in a chair
and they asked him to do a bunch of different things like:
eat, yawn, a variety of vocalizations, and lip smacks.
While he was doing this
they shot x-ray video of him.
And then what they did with this x-ray video
is they actually used it to reconstruct his
vocal anatomy.
How he created sounds.
And then they fed this into a computer program
and they had this computer program
say the audio that you just played:
Will you marry me?
Based on that they concluded that yes
monkeys theoretically could talk like people.
Right.
I listened to the human version of this.
so they did something similar with people.
I'll play it:
Will you marry me?
It doesn't sound that much different.
So this isn't really saying monkeys sound like --
ghostly voices.
It's just --this is the best the computer simulation
can do with those components?
Exactly.
Fundamentally what it's showing
in the very least -
we can argue about the quality of the recording
but it shows that at least monkeys could
theoretically produce these types of sounds.
And if heard them,
we would be able to understand what they were saying.